almost two and a half million people
have taken shelter from cyclone am fan
an evacuation made all the more
challenging bike Ovid 19 it was the
strongest tropical storm on record as it
tracked north through the Bay of Bengal
with wind speeds of 270 miles an hour
but they were barely half that by the
time the vortex made landfall close to
the border of Bangladesh and India
scientists believe the record sea
temperatures that fueled the storm may
have been caused in part by more
sunlight filtering through pollution
free skies during the pandemic lockdown
is that there is much more radiation
which has come because of lack of
aerosols and also produced clothes so it
has one more now and in this condition a
cyclone has pom so what has happened is
that cyclone we all know it basically
depends upon the heat content of the
ocean so more heat content into more
intense is the cycle time a change is
fueling super storms the sea temperature
in the Bay of Bengal reached 34 degrees
in the first two weeks of May the energy
from such warm water whips up the wind
speed strong storms are increasing by 8%
a decade rising temperatures also
increase rainfall from storms research
suggests it will surge by 20% in the
coming decades the new normal of climate
change will make poorer countries even
more vulnerable to other emergencies
such as pandemics this is a clear view
what happens when two crises come
together now Bangladesh a dealing with
the coded 19 outbreak at the same time
they've now got a deal with a super
cyclone heading their way
and and needs these sort of combined or
compound problems really where you see
no serious issues and that's what we've
got to mitigate for in the future as
well it's it's not just climate change
impacts it's when climate change
coincides with one of these other sort
of vermin outbreaks this is likely to be
the strongest storm to hit the area
since a cyclone in 2007 killed three and
a half thousand
people the pandemic is an extra hazard
this time round and authorities are
opening up schools and other large
buildings as cyclone shelters to reduce
the risk of the corona virus spreading
through overcrowding Thomas More Sky
News